Welcome back.
In this presentation, I
actually want to show you how
we can use the antiderivative
to figure out the
area under a curve.
Actually I'm going to focus
more a little bit more
on the intuition.
So let actually use an
example from physics.
I'll use distance and velocity.
And actually this could be a
good review for derivatives,
or actually an application
of derivatives.
So let's say that I
described the position
of something moving.
Let's say it's x.
Let's say that x is equal to,
I don't know, 16t squared.
Right?
So s is distance.
Let me write this
in the corner.
I don't know why the
convention is to use s as
the variable for distance.
One would think, well actually,
I know, why won't they use d?
Because d is the letter used
for differential, I guess.
So s is equal to distance,
and then t is equal to time.
So this is just a formula that
tells us the position, kind of
how far has something
gone, after x many, let's
say, seconds, right?
So after like, 4 seconds, we
would have gone, let's say
the distance is in feet,
this is in seconds.
After 4 seconds, we would
have gone 256 feet.
That's all that says.
And let me graph that as well.
Graph it.
That's a horrible line.
Have to use the line tool,
might have better luck.
It's slightly better.
Actually, let me undo that too,
because I just want to do
it for positive t, right?
Because you can't really
go back in time.
For the purposes of this
lecture, you can't
go back in time.
So that'll have to do.
So this curve will essentially
just be a parabola, right?
It'll look something like this.
So actually, if you
look at it, I mean you
could just eyeball it.
The object, every second you
go, it's going a little
bit further, right?
So it's actually accelerating.
And so what if we wanted to
figure out what the velocity
of this object, right?
This is, let's see, this
is d, this is t, right?
And this is, I don't know
if it's clear, but this is
kind of 1/2 a parabola.
So this is the
distance function.
What would the velocity be?
Well the velocity is
just, what's velocity?
It's distance divided
by time, right?
And since this velocity
is always changing, we
want to figure out the
instantaneous velocity.
And that's actually one of the
initial uses of what made
derivatives so useful.
So we want to find the change,
the instantaneous change
with respect to time of
this formula, right?
Because this is the
distance formula.
So if we know the instant rate
of change of distance with
respect to time, we'll
know the velocity, right?
So ds, dt, is equal to?
So what's the derivative here?
It's 32t, right?
And this is the velocity.
Maybe I should switch back
to, let me write that,
v equals velocity.
I don't know why I switched
colors, but I'll stick
with the yellow.
So let's graph this function.
This will actually be a fairly
straightforward graph to draw.
It's pretty straight.
And then we draw the x-axis.
I'm doing pretty good.
OK.
So this, I'll draw it in
red, this is this going
to be a line, right?
32t it's a line with slope 32.
So it's actually a
pretty steep line.
I won't draw it that steep
because I'm going to use
this for an illustration.
So this is the velocity.
This is velocity.
This is that graph, and
this is distance, right?
So in case you hadn't learned
already, and maybe I'll do a
whole presentation on kind of
using calculus for physics, and
using derivatives for physics.
But if you have to distance
formula, it's derivative
is just velocity.
And I guess if you view
it the other way, if you
have the velocity, it's
antiderivative is distance.
Although you won't know
where, at what position,
the object started.
In this case, the object
started at position of 0,
but it could be, you know,
at any constant, right?
You could have started
here and then curved up.
But anyway, let's just
assume we started at 0.
So the derivative of distance
is velocity, the antiderivative
of velocity is distance.
Keep that in mind.
Well let's look at this.
Let's assume that we were
only given this graph.
And we said, you know,
this is the graph of the
velocity of some object.
And we want to figure out what
the distance is after, you
know, t seconds, right?
So this is the t-axis, this
is the velocity axis, right?
So let's say we were only given
this, and let's say we didn't
know that the antiderivative of
the velocity function is
the distance function.
How would we figure out, how
would we figure out what
the distance would be
at any given time?
Well let's think about it.
If we have a constant, this
red is kind of bloody.
Let me switch to
something more pleasant.
If we have, over any small
period of time, right, or if we
have a constant velocity, when
you have a constant velocity,
distance is just velocity
times time, right?
So let's say we had
a very small time
fragment here, right?
I'll draw it big, but let's
say this time fragment
it is really small.
And let's called this very
small time fragment, let call
this delta t, or dt actually.
The way I've used dt is like,
it's like a change in time
that's unbelievably
small, right?
So it's like almost
instantaneous, but not quite.
Or you can actually view
it as instantaneous.
So this is how much
time goes by.
You can kind of view this as
a very small change in time.
So if we have a very small
change of time, and over that
very small change in time,
we have a roughly constant
velocity, let's say the roughly
constant velocity is this.
Right, this is the velocity, so
say we had over this very small
change in time, we have this
roughly constant velocity
that's on this graph.
Actually, let me
take do it here.
We have this roughly
constant velocity.
So the distance that the object
travels over the small time
would be the small time
times the velocity, right?
It would be whatever the value
of this red line is, times the
width of this distance, right?
So what's another way?
Visually I kind of did
it ahead of time, but
what's happening here?
If I take this change in time,
right, which is kind of the
base of this rectangle, and I
multiply it times the velocity
which is really just the height
of this rectangle, what
have I figured out?
Well I figured out the area
of this rectangle, right?
Right, the velocity this
moment, times the change in
time at this moment, is
nothing but the area of
this very skinny rectangle.
Skinny and tall, right?
It's almost infinitely skinny,
but it's, we're assuming for
these purposes it has some very
notional amount of width.
So there we figured out the
area of this column, right?
Well, if we wanted to figure
out the distance that you
travel after, let's say, you
know, I don't know, let's say
t, let's say t sub
nought, right?
This is just a particular t.
After t sub nought
seconds, right?
Well then, all we would have to
do is, we would have to just
figure, we would just do
a bunch of dt's, right?
You'd do another one here,
you'd figure out the area of
this column, you'd figure out
the area of this column, the
area of this column, right?
Because each of these areas
of each of these columns
represents the distance
that the object travels
over that dt, right?
So if you wanted to know how
far you traveled after t sub
zero seconds, you'd essentially
get, or an approximation would
be, the sum of all
of these areas.
And as you got more and more,
as you made the dt's smaller
and smaller, skinnier,
skinnier, skinnier.
And you had more and more and
more and more of these
rectangles, then your
approximation will get pretty
close to, well, two things.
It'll get pretty close to, as
you can imagine, the area
under this curve, or
in this case a line.
But it would also get you
pretty much the exact amount
of distance you've traveled
after t sub nought seconds.
So I think I'm running into the
ten minute wall, so I'm just
going to pause here, and I'm
going to continue this in
the next presentation.